[Music]
A car. We crossed the border for 180 kilometers, or turn a little, and
we got out in the morning, God willing. We
want to start helping the world today, God willing.
Peace is
ringing. I mean, maybe the place or next to it
as well. We are coming to help the sisters. I mean, there is no
country, no, and no strong equipment. There is absolutely
no.  There are small equipment warehouses, all the work is manual,
and whole families under the houses
[Music]
Poetry
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
I mean, the interaction of the world. Hello, I am
masters of medicines, foodstuffs, money, I mean, the people
we in Syria need, despite all this, remove them from
their needs
[Music] [
music]